geld gibt es für diese arbeit nicht
trotzdem kommt ahmed salim jeden tag
hierher und er klotzt dran als ginge es
um sein leben und tatsächlich ein wenig
ist das auch so für ihn und die anderen
geht es um weit mehr als um die chance
auf einen job
ich möchte etwas tun um zu beweisen wer
ich bin und wie ich meinen beitrag zur
gesellschaft leisten der elektriker floh
vor dem terror der boko haram aus
nigeria in libyen baute er sich ein
neues leben auf dann kam der bürgerkrieg
und er musste erneut fliehen
nur knapp schaffte er es auf einen
schiffbrüchigen bot vor die küste
italiens dorthin soll er jetzt zurück
gehen
jeder weiß dass es in italien keine
arbeit gibt nicht einmal für die
italiener
was soll ich als fremder da machen
deswegen liegen alle seine hoffnungen
auf diesen kurs in berliner pilotprojekt
arriva werden er und 24 andere
flüchtlinge auf das berufsleben in
deutschland vorbereitet mit einem
ausbildungsvertrag in der hand steigt
für sie die chance im land bleiben zu
dürfen
hier fähige leute brauchen wir sind
fähige leute direkt vor eurer tür wenn
er sie trotzdem fort schicken wollte wo
wollt ihr die fähigen leute her neben
fachkräfte wie auch ihre keller co der
maler hat als kind schon einmal in
deutschland gelebt sieben jahre lang
seine familie war vor dem krieg im
kosovo geflohen
als dort wieder frieden herrscht mussten
sie zurück für den damals neunjährigen
war das ein schock
ich weiß noch die ersten zwei jahre
hatte ich habe ich auch in koserow nur
durch gesprochen auch in schule da kann
ich nicht so konnten wir so gut hat war
nicht immer so hipp albanisch aber zu
hause mit meinem vater mutter und
brüdern nur durch
auf dem ausbildungs hof der berliner
bauhandwerker das baugewerbe sucht
händeringend nachwuchs deshalb können
die flüchtlinge hier ausprobieren wo
ihre talente liegen alle zwei tage
lernen sie einen neuen beruf kennen und
potenzielle arbeitgeber ilja kabakow ist
heute weil den stuckateure den beruf
würde er sehr gerne lernen
es kann er beweisen dass er das zeug
dazu hat
ahmed cdu ist heute bei den kanal bauern
bisher hatte elektriker von allen
handwerksmeistern hier nur top noten
bekommen und auch wenn er selbst noch
nicht so gut deutsch spricht
der nigerianer hat keine probleme den
anweisungen der ausbilder zu folgen
auch bei mauern arbeitet er geschickt
und sorgsam der meister ist begeistert
dabei
der 29 jährige nigerianer ist einer von
ihnen
das problem er bekommt keine
arbeitserlaubnis in deutschland
stattdessen droht ihm die abschiebung
nach italien
trotzdem ist er jeden morgen pünktlich
hier was ich vorher nicht kannte
das ist schön die sozialarbeiterin des
flüchtlings projektes will 48 mit seiner
kämpfen
sie plant eine petition an die politik
damit er doch noch bleiben kann
das ist sozusagen und ich hoffe da
eigentlich sehr stark darauf dass da
noch mal sein
berufsbedingte fähigkeiten zum ausdruck
kommen also nicht nur dass er irgendwie
politisch engagierter typ ist der
versucht sich ja auch so einzugliedern
und der deutschland und der sich
vernetzt werkt hat mittlerweile in
berlin sondern auch einer der einfach
hier einer ist den die wirtschaft gerne
will
und tatsächlich verstehen die deutschen
unternehmen immer weniger
warum sie auf mitarbeiter wie ahmed
salim verzichten sollen
die berliner bauhandwerker starten
deshalb einen testballon
sie haben drei flüchtlinge ausgewählt
die ein praktikum bekommen und dann in
eine ausbildung vermittelt werden sollen
ilja kabakow ist einer von ihnen
er hat nicht nur erfolgreich seine erste
gips säule gegossen sondern ist seinem
traum in deutschland leben und arbeiten
zu können einen großen schritt näher
gekommen